Speaker 1: Well, a blockbuster new House
Republican report has investigated President
Joe Biden and it has found absolutely no
wrongdoing by President Joe Biden. It's
really important whenever you hear they won't
even let us investigate. Big Pharma won't let us
investigate whether niacin works for depression.
Oh, actually, there's a bunch of studies on that
that's been investigated. Oh, well, they won't
let us investigate what had the vaccine. Oh,
the vaccine's been investigated and they
won't let us test whether hydroxychloroquine,
when snorted through a neti pot, treats cold. It's
they looked at hydroxychloroquine so many times at
this point. So whenever you hear we're not even
allowed to. Well, let's look as you were hearing
on Fox News and elsewhere, that they simply can't
get what they need. The whistleblower is missing.
It's all being obstructed. They don't know what
crimes Hunter Biden or Joe Biden might have,
might have committed. You go to The New York
Times, which, by the way, isn't failing and
it's certainly not fake. And you find house.
Wait a second. What House Republican report
finds no evidence of wrongdoing by President
Biden after months of investigation, months?
They've been they've been looking into this. Yes.
After months of investigation and many public
accusations of corruption against Mr. Biden and
his family, the first report of the premier House
Republican, this is a Republican inquiry showed no
proof of such misconduct. What? And here you see
Republicans on the oversight committee standing
very strongly and announcing we didn't find any
wrongdoing. They investigated for months. We'll
link to this article by Luke Broadwater. It's a
good summary. For months of investigation, House
Republicans promised to use their majority to
unearth evidence of wrongdoing by Biden,
acknowledged that they had yet to uncover
any incriminating material about him, despite
frequent insinuations that he and his family have
been involved in criminal conduct and corruption.
Even the Republicans can't find it. Well,
it must be a cover up, right? I mean, these Soros
backed Republicans must have been up to no good or
something along those lines at a much publicized
news conference on Capitol Hill. Can you imagine
the build up? We're finally going to hear about
it. They're holding a press conference. They're
going to come with the with the the the receipts.
And we're going to find out once and for all,
all of the crimes that Biden committed. And they
go, yeah, we actually have no our preliminary
findings are no wrongdoing whatsoever. We
found no incriminating evidence at all.
They released financial documents
detailing how some of the president's
relatives were paid money during a period of
time. They are calling it influence peddling,
but there's not actually any evidence of that.
And they've conceded that there is no evidence
of a specific corrupt action that Biden has taken
while in office, not a single corrupt action in
connection with any of the business deals that
Hunter Biden was involved in. They said I mean,
I don't know what else to say. They just they
don't have any evidence. It also the article
also explains federal prosecutors have examined
Hunter Biden's international business activities
as part of a criminal investigation, but the only
charges they're considering are unrelated to his
work abroad. They include tax charges related to
failure to file tax returns for several years and
lying about his drug use on a federal file, a
form he filled out to purchase a handgun. Hey,
you know what? If that's what you've got, Hunter
Biden won, by all means, go ahead and prosecute.
Charge him. I don't see anyone on the left
running interference for Hunter Biden to point
out that Hunter Biden has nothing to do with Joe
Biden's presidency, that Joe Biden's presidency
has not exhibited any evidence of crime
or fraud of any sort. And by the way,
if there were such evidence, I would want to
know about it. I wouldn't work to cover it up.
As someone who voted for Biden over Trump, if we
have evidence that a president engaged in fraud,
I don't care whether they're a Democrat or
a Republican, I want to see the evidence. So
many Republicans responding to this report by
saying clearly this is part of the cover up.
Soros got to the Oversight Committee. Maybe it
was Antifa, but what they are doing is wasting
more and more and more time and resources and
taxpayer money for nothing. It may be time,
by the way, to close up Obama gate as well. You
still remember when Trump told us Obama gate was
the crime of the century, the political crime of
the century? And a reporter said, Can you tell us
what the. Crimes were. And Trump looked at them
and with a straight face said, you know what they
are? You know what they are. Well, maybe it's time
to close the book on Obama Gate as well. I don't
know where we're going on that, but certainly
don't seem to be making any progress whatsoever.